Graduated high school,
crushed it,
straight A's,
boom.
Help my classmates with kindness kind and helpful and expected them to be.
Meanwhile,
they put me down,
mocked me,
never loved me in a room with 30 people.
I was always alone.
Inner voice tells me to go after the past.
Seek revenge.
Keep looking at their profiles.
Profiles,
online profiles.
Social media.
Yeah.
Should I go now?
He's got a series of questions here.
Should I go after them and try to fix the past,
either by revenge or else should I,
should I remove them from social media and leave the the Facebook group?
Should I attend the reunion?
Why have they even been in my life?
Okay,
so let's break those down.
Number one,
should I go after them and try to fix the past either by revenge or something
else to answer that,
in my opinion is no man,
who cares?
They're high school kids.
Move on.
Get on with your life.
Yeah.
Disagree.
Agree.
Okay.
That,
that one to me is pretty straight forward.
Don't worry about these humans.
I actually had a couple conversations with,
with uh,
my oldest daughters haven't had this one with my son yet,
but my older daughters,
which is,
hey look,
these people that are around right now that you think are so important in high
school,
they're not,
you know,
some of them might be,
you might have some lifelong friends from high school.
I get that.
But these people that are not nice to you,
you won't be thinking about them.
So I don't,
I'm not sure how old this individual is,
but he's got a couple more years before you won't be thinking about these people
anymore.
So just get there earlier question too.
Should I remove them from social media and leave this Facebook group?
Okay.
This is a little bit tricky in my opinion.
Uh,
first of all,
if you can,
if you can stay,
if you can keep them on social media,
but ignore them completely,
just leave me alone.
Just leave it and just totally ignore them because when you leave them or
whatever,
you're kind of,
aren't you kind of making the scene?
Okay.
I just want to make sure.
So you want to make it seem well yeah,
like when you unfriend them or whatever,
which didn't you and I have some situations with the athlete.
Yeah.
Actually.
So,
okay.
So
I know that I,
wait,
who unfriended you?
My wife.
Yep.
Okay,
so you did it well,
no,
no.
I didn't even know how to do it.
Non You figured it out.
No,
I didn't.
So I didn't ever have social media until two years ago,
but all of a sudden I saw echo friends with my wife and I said,
Woo.
She's like showing me something.
And she says,
and I see echo.
And I said,
well,
why are you friends with people that,
why are you friends with people that I know on a,
or click on friend on that.
And I didn't even know it was a big deal.
I just thought,
you know,
hey,
that means,
and,
and then I didn't realize a big deal.
It's a big deal,
man.
Unfriended him messed up.
I thought you did it per purposefully knowing it's a big deal,
but not understanding that it's even a bigger deal than you know,
the kind where you're like unpruned him as a joke.
That was like,
it was totally your personality at that.
I did that to you.
Yeah.
Like as a joke,
like unfriend them,
you know,
say something to me like immediately or was it,
did that a month go by where I didn't make a joke about it?
I forget.
So,
so it is kind of making a scene.
Yeah.
If you,
if you unfriend this person or you leave the group,
then you're just creating a little firestorm.
But I will say this,
if you can't,
if you can't keep yourself from checking on them,
then you might have to do that.
So try it for a couple of weeks.
Just say,
I'm not looking at them.
Yeah.
Let them go.
Just leave him.
If you can't do that,
then delete them and leave the group or whatever.
So the number three,
should I attend the reunion?
Okay.
My answer to that is negative.
Don't.
Why would you?
These people are negative.
They have,
they bring back negative memories.
They didn't treat you well,
they,
but why would you?
You don't need to move on again.
Key Word I think.
Move on.
Yeah.
And then the last question is why have they even been in my life?
Well,
I think just like anything else bad that happens in life,
the things that are bad that happen in life can either teach you or break you
and you've got to decide what you want them to do.
I vote that you,
you allow it to teach you.
I,
I voted.
You learn from these people that you learn how to forget about the past.
That you learn how to ignore people that are negative,
that you learn to control your vengeful ideas and that you learn to move on into
the future where you're going to meet better people and better times it'd be at,
that's what I would recommend.
Don't worry about these people from the past.
They're caught up in this weird world.
Yeah.
High School.
This is high school.
Caught up in high school world.
Don't worry about high school.
Get into the world.
Yeah,
right.
Big Time.
Well,
well got,
I've had one daughter that now graduated from high school.
I got two kids in high school right now.
Drama.
There's drama,
but actually believe it or not,
there hasn't been a lot of drama with my kids.
Not a lot of high school drama.
That doesn't surprise me but,
but I see it,
it does happen.
And I remember the drama.
I'd say it.
My guess,
I don't know.
It's been a long time since high school for me personally.
But yeah,
man,
I think that's life.
You know,
high school is drama.
You with a bunch of kids not knowing nothing.
Is there more drama in high school than there is in life?
Maybe it's because it's stuck together.
Yeah.
Like you look at your stuff depends on your life.
Like if you just consider a typical high school versus my life.
Yeah.
Way More in high schools in Miami,
your drama,
that's it.
You're not even really a job really.
Yeah.
They're all high school.
All of them.
Even this guy obviously,
you know,
so it's going to feel like way more than it is for sure.
But you know,
when you,
when you the,
the further you go along in life,
the more you realize that this means less and less,
these types of things anyway,
when you consider it high school is really just for learning.
Sure.
You learn social [inaudible] to,
you know what I just thought of it is,
is what's interesting about this is if you're looking back on high school,
either with fond memories or with negative Ben you way,
it's not a great thing because you could be like uncle Rico from Napoleon
dynamite.
Right.
Who's constantly living back his high school football games.
Yeah.
And he's wishing he made that pass and you know what I mean,
won the state championship or whatever.
Yeah.
You get that.
That's not good.
That means you're stuck in high school.
You peaked in high school.
Yeah.
If you're looking back at the negative things,
same thing.
Yes.
And who,
no,
move forward.
Yeah.
In his defense though,
obviously he just graduated,
so he's in life really.
Is it really,
you know,
it's still new.
It's like,
you know,
someone stuff's going to happen,
brother.
You just move on and get after it.
Yeah.
Probably the social media thing though,
I'll say this cause there's,
there's little levels of like unfriending whether you can unfollow someone.
I'm assuming this is Facebook.
I don't know.
There's,
you know,
there's so many,
he could be talking about other stuff,
but on Facebook you can still remain,
remain friends,
but just unfollow them so you won't get all their stuff.
Do they know that?
I don't think so.
I'm sure many people have unfollowed me and I don't know that I've never gotten
the alert or whatever.
Um,
I would say leave the group fully.
Oh yeah.
I would listen to your advice more than me because I don't understand it as much
as you do.
I don't,
I don't understand the Facebook group thing.
Yeah.
I mean,
depends how many people it seemed like who's was going to make a scene.
I don't like to make a scene.
Yeah.
So I'd be like,
well no,
I'm just gonna ignore it.
Yeah.
I don't think leaving the group is a scene.
If it is,
I mean obviously depends on how many people in the group is less people in the
group though more of a scene it's going to be,
or if he's always posting,
if he's the head of the group or something like this,
then yeah.
You know how in the past there was etiquette schools I went to,
I went to etiquette classes when I went to officer candidate school in
Pensacola,
Florida.
And they teach you which knife to use,
all that stuff,
and they teach you things.
For instance,
you might not know this.
If you take a bite of food and there's something in that bite of food that you
don't want to eat a bone of,
whatever.
The way to properly get it out of your mouth is to use your fork putting on the
fork and put it back down on the plate.
So like,
yeah.
Okay,
Gotcha.
They would say the same.
So that's the type of thing.
Yeah,
there should be a class
or we're going to a point where people are gonna need a class on social media
etiquette.
Yeah.
Actually it's not a bad idea.
You should teach it.
All right,
let's move on.
I think so.
Yeah.
The high school move on,
Dude.
Move on,
brother.
Move on.